all right just just set it down right
over there yeah I'm exhausted
you said building all these applications
is tough work I don't know what I'm
gonna do when they need to be stateful
you know kubernetes on Google cloud
platform is a great way to host stateful
applications with high availability that
would save me a ton of headaches sounds
great let's jump into a demo and show
you how quickly we can get this all set
up
let's start with an application running
on gke that requires state a simple
example would be the popular blogging
platform WordPress so this is our
WordPress architecture as represented by
kubernetes objects we have to keep ODS
the WordPress pod which runs a wordpress
container annamaria DB pod which runs
the backend database both of these pods
are controlled by deployments and
replica sets which can be scaled up
kubernetes services give us a stable
method of accessing these pods no matter
the count of replicas the Morea DB pot
is fronted by an internal service type
cluster IP while the WordPress pods are
exposed to the public via an external
service type load balancer this is where
we want to focus our demo today both of
these pods require state WordPress needs
to store assets and its file system and
Maria DB stores post and user data so we
have a storage class that defines the
type of persistent volume that each pod
will get in our case here we will want
to create a storage class for the
regional persistent disk each pod will
then have a persistent volume claim for
their respective persistent volumes now
let's take a look at how the world
worked before regional persistent disks
were available let's start with a single
zone gke cluster in this case we have
GCE persistent disks scoped to a single
zone mounted to the nodes where our pods
are running if there is any level of
failure on these nodes we're fortunate
to have kubernetes self-heal and kick'n
these pods will migrate to healthy
available nodes and the disk due to
persistent volume claims will be able to
migrate to the new nodes retaining state
for our pods all as well but this isn't
everyone set up more and more we're
looking for reliability in our
applications which means we want to
spread across multiple failure domains
so in gke customers are adopting
regional clusters which means the
control plane is replicated across
multiple zones as are the nodes that the
applications run on in this demo we will
have nodes running in uswest 1b and
uswest 1c with a persistent disk scoped
to a zone we'll run into issues to get
the high availability with desire if
there is a zonal failure pods will
continue to migrate to a different zone
with healthy nodes but because the
persistent disk is scoped to a single
zone the state cannot follow enter
regional persistent disks
in this same scenario we can now migrate
the state to a different zone as it was
being synchronously replicated by the
regional PDS let's jump into the demo
and see it in action so here is our
regional google kubernetes engine
cluster it's running in us West one with
nodes in zones B and C let's use coop
control to actually look at the pods
deployments and service objects that
comprise our WordPress application so as
you can see we have one of each pod for
WordPress Andrea DB and we also have an
external load balancer running the
WordPress pod so if we actually throw
that into the browser will see our
WordPress blog and it's titled hello
take five will see that if we dive into
the blog section we actually have one
blog post titled nice blog take five and
so we can see that our state is actually
stored on the persistent volumes mounted
to the Maria DB in the WordPress pod and
we can actually use coop control to look
at those objects as well so we'll look
at the persistent volumes the persistent
volume claims and the specific storage
class that defines the regional
persistent disk so we can see that our
claims actually represent bounded
persistent volumes and if we actually
dive into and describe our storage class
we'll see that we've created a very
specific type for regional persistent
disk we'll see here defined in the
parameters that we have replication type
regional persistent disk we'll see that
it's a persistent disk standard and it's
running in zones or it's replicated
across the zones uswest 1b and uswest 1c
so now we will want to see the high
availability in action with regional PDS
by simulating a zonal failure this
script title big red button has a
command at the end that will actually
take out one of the zones where my nodes
are running for this gke cluster so once
I execute that script the script will
actually identify where both the Maria
DB and the WordPress pods are running so
now we see the actual node that the pot
is running on and we see that that node
is located in u.s. wes 1b and so we are
now going to simulate that failure in
u.s. wes 1b and we will have to answer
yes to that prompt
and now we'll perform a watch to see
what actually happens with our pods when
they are moved into the node running in
us West 1c okay and now we've actually
sped through the zonal failure to see
that our pods have successfully
rescheduled from the node in u.s. 1b to
the node in u.s. West 1c now to see if
state actually followed into the new
zone let's jump into our wordpress blog
so if we refresh the page we actually
see that our blog is still there with
the same title and let's look at that
blog post nice blog take five is still
present and nothing has changed about it
great so we can see how easy it is to
use google cribben in his engine to host
stateful highly available applications
absolutely don't forget to Like comment
and subscribe and if you'd like to get
in contact with us click on the link in
the description
[Music]